Charlotte Pauline alisé Kim au total 15
beautés ont défilé ce samedi dans le
centre commercial Paris Ouest de morpa
pour décrocher le titre convoité de Miss
Eveline 2013 je postule aujourd'hui dans
l'espire de pouvoir représenter la femme
aujourd'hui de nos jours qui est
indépendante et
ambe après la parade en robe de soirée
les jeunes femmes sont passées en
maillot de bain toujours en talon haut
en musique et sous les encouragements du
public un événement placé sous le signe
glamour en présence de notre miss
france€ je suis pas là pour juger voilà
je suis vraiment là pour leur donner des
conseils si elle m'en demande et je leur
diraiis simplement de de profiter de ces
momentsl pour s'amuser pour d'être
souriante de montrer qu'elles sont
contentes d'être là tout simplement le
chemin
début sera long jusqu'à l'écharpe de
Miss France mais il y en aura une et et
moi je serai très contente l'année
prochaine de remettre mon
écharpe venu soutenir les candidats date
marine l'orphelin en a profité pour une
rencontre dédicace avec ses
fans pendant ce temps le jury délibéré
et les apprentis mis patienté avec leurs
proches parmi elle Anaïs pour laquelle
nous avions eu un coup de cœur elle
évoque avant le résultat les qualités
pour être élu faut être souriante c'est
important il faut être soi-même et faut
avoir de la grâce et voilà faut savoir
bien s s'exprimer aussi et puis être
belle
j'imagine c'est sa maman originaire de
la Martinique qui l'a inscrite
secrètement à l'élection dans l'espoir
qu'elle soit sacrée je serais très Fiè
de ma fille très Fiè et puis pour sa
mamie aussi qui n'est plus là et qui
trouvait qu'elle avait une chance aussi
d'être élu Miss France ou Miss Yveline
et justement Miss yeline 2013 et la
candidate numéro
4ï
sur fond d'hyne officiel du comité Miss
France le rêve commence pour l'étudiante
en BTS tourisme à
guillancour je suis surpris je suis
heureuse et voilà plein de bonnes choses
qui vont arriver
j'imagine prochaine date le 26 juin
Anaïs du haut de son maître 71
participera à l'élection Miss Île-de
France